oh wire bartender so hot that's a real
question I don't know if that's even
true
I am cam Montgomery jr. bartender
extraordinaire you know what my friends
I have bartended since 1998 I'm Augusta
Gail and I've been bartending for seven
plus years now today I'm gonna ask you
some of the most commonly googled
questions about bars and bartending
why are bartender so important oh no
people are having that poisoning
experiences maybe we're just cranky from
all the drunk people depends on the day
I guess I try really hard not to be a
cranky bartender but the longer I've
been doing it I totally understand why
if you need a bartender who's rude it's
because of the customer it's because the
customer is going or the customer is
taking a straw or something and throwing
it at the bartender to get his attention
or banging on the bar nobody wants to
deal with that it depends on the bar - I
was a lot harsher and crankier when I
worked at dive bars where I had to be
cutting people off and kicking people
out sorry tell you people who've had
rude bartender just come see me I'm not
rude most of the time how do our tenders
keep track of tabs depends on the system
depends on the bar I've worked at bars
where you actually physically take every
card and you put it in like a little
slot with the last name and you just
keep them all in there some bars are
fancy and have those systems where you
can just like swipe the card and give it
back and then just run the charge at the
end of the night all right now don't get
upset with me when I tell you this a lot
of times you know you guys will give
your credit card and then we will write
something on that little piece of paper
whatever so that we know ball head black
guy with missing front teeth and wrap
that around the credit card so that I
know that's who it is you just have to
write a little note so that you know
who's who and then sometimes you might
end up charging somebody that didn't buy
that drink wire bartender so hot wire
bartenders so hot that's a real question
that's nice that's flattering it's my
low ego boost for the day well I've
noticed in the club's here in LA in
particular they really want hot women
bartenders and the reason for that is so
that the me
who come in we'll spin all the money no
if you go to a gay bar in West Hollywood
they have hot dudes for the same reason
if they're hot for some reason people a
buy more drinks and B leave more tips it
takes a certain personality I think to
be a good bartender you have to be
outgoing you have to kind of have a
charisma about you and I think sometimes
people interpret that as hotness
well bartenders be replaced by robots I
hope that robots will never be able to
replace the human element in the
spontaneity that you get from a real
living breathing weird awkward human
behind the bar
I certainly hope not I can't see that
happening because I can't see a robot
pouring the drink the way you really
want it because the robots only gonna do
it a certain way and if you want a
little extra or something like that how
does it robot gonna do that so obviously
no I think a lot of people go to bars
for that human connection and to talk
and to unload and to have a interaction
with somebody that is not their computer
or their phone how did bars make green
beer oh yeah we do a green dye just like
you made green jello we just put food
coloring in the beer which is gross
don't drink green beer that's nasty it
what do bars do with fake IDs it depends
on the bar depends on the policy a lot
of times security handles that too I
worked at bars though where we've just
had stacks of fake IDs that just live
behind the bar when we know for sure
that the IDs fake you take it and you
cut it you cut it up and to kick that
person out well you know what the next
time you go on Google and you want to
ask a question about bartenders I want
you to just ask your question whatever
it is and there's no question that's too
stupid there's no question that's smart
and you know Google has the answer for
everything and if Google doesn't you
come right back here to BuzzFeed and ask
for cam I'll tell you if you're going
out to bars just be responsible have fun
drink what you like be nice to your
bartender I don't know what else to say
I'm so lucky yeah robot can't be awkward
so come see me Anna
[Music]